[Musique]
Kovit a mis la pression
dans tout le pays, le
café fait pression sur l'industrie funéraire
[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas à l'abri de cela,
nous avons un peu plus de 190 balles ici
sur ces 190 corps, je dirai en toute sécurité
100  de ceux qui sont
réellement couverts
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent, nous avons distribué 22
de ces conteneurs à travers le pays
dans diverses régions
où nous pensons devoir
renforcer nos installations mortuaires
[Musique]
mais le plus grand impact auquel nous sommes confrontés
en ce moment est
la pénurie de matière première
tu sais ça perturbe la production
il fait
des empires il nous met en échec